what we have seen so far is
social science explanations why clusters
appear in networks and what we are going
to do next
is to start talking about methods that
build on the intuition i have just
explained
and actually uh identify these clusters
in networks so um let's start with what
we have learned so far right like
granovator's theory suggests that
networks are composed from
tightly connected clusters or sets of
nodes
um and the connections inside the
clusters are strong
uh interpersonally socially and these
connections across the clusters are
weak are more like acquaintance
relationships
we can call these clusters also
communities
we call them groups we call them modules
it is kind of
all the same right and uh
we are going to use the word network
communities to refer
with to refer to sets of nodes with a
lot of internal connections
and few uh external ones meaning a few
to the rest
of the of the network
so now the question will be given given
a
uh a network how do we find these uh
densely connected groups of nodes
ideally you know we would
like uh uh then these density
connected groups of nodes to then
correspond to real
underlying uh social communities so let
me give you a few examples of this
so for example one most
famous and most used social network is
called
zachary's karate club network and
zachary was also a phd student and he
was studying
uh social relationships in a university
karate club
and this is the social network of that
university karate club but what was
interesting is that during the study
the conflicts led this karate club to
split into two groups
and what is interesting is that actually
here the split
is denoted that circles went and created
one
a new karate club and the squares
remained in the old
karate club and what is striking
is that basically this network kind of
split in the middle
right like the circles went on one end
and the
squares went on the other so it's not
that you know a random set of nodes
would decide to form a new club but it's
kind of one part of the network
separated out itself out right and
actually
the the the way you could automatically
find
this uh this split is to simply say
how do i split the nodes of this network
into two sets so that the number of
edges that crosses
between the two sets meaning goes from
one set of nodes to the other
um is minimized right so basically this
was one of the first
examples that basically communities
happen based on the underlying network
structure and that you can predict
which humans are going to join one team
and which humans are going to join the
other team
based on the social relationships
between them perhaps that is kind of
obvious and well known to us today but
back in 60s
this was totally miraculous right it
wasn't at all expected that it's
actually
social connections that make uh that
play such a big role
in uh how uh groups uh and communities
forum
um another example of groups and
communities is in a very different part
of the world
so it is in online advertising where
basically if you think you are google or
facebook
you have advertisers who say who where
do they want their ads to be shown
so you can create this bipartite graph
where you put advertisers at the bottom
and you put queries or keywords on the
other side
and then here i'm kind of showing the
adjacency matrix where a dot means that
a given advertiser
wants its ads to be shown when a given
query a given keyword a given a person
with a given
interest uh shows up and what you find
out is that there are these well-defined
dance clusters where you know groups of
advertisers
beat or advertise on common keywords or
on common
interests and you know here is one
example of uh
you know the gambling set of advertisers
who are
gambling on people who are advertising
on people
interesting in in gambling uh queries so
it allows you to identify um micro
markets
subgroups in this type of online
advertising space
another example is you know imagine you
take a network of
ncaa university football teams and you
connect to teams if they play games with
each other
and here's the visualization of the
network and the question is
is there any structure in how teams play
each other
and if you run these community detection
methods you would actually identify the
the groups here they are visualized
right so notice this network
is the same as that network right so
this is just visualize the network this
is what the visualization comes up with
it doesn't seem
there is any real structure here right
maybe you say oh there seems to be
something here and maybe there is a
cluster here
i don't know maybe there's something
here it's very hard to say
but after you apply a community
detection method it will actually go
and identify uh the clusters and here
they are
and what is interesting and right is
that they actually exactly correspond
to these conferences uh in which
teams are organized where teams play
each other inside
the conference more than with other
conferences and you even have a couple
of teams
that are that are not part of any
community because they are
part of this independence conference and
they just kind of play
with different teams so this is how for
example we can extract structure of them
out of the network even though initially
this structure
is not obvious to give you
another example now is to say how do we
formalize this right how do we identify
these sets of tightly connected
nodes and the way we are going to do
this
is that we are going to specify a
metric that we call modularity and we
are and this metric will measure
how well a network is partitioned into
communities
so given a partitioning of the network
into
groups of nodes let's assume that right
now somebody gives us this partitioning
we are going to compute this modularity
score q
and if we have the modularity uh score
defined
then what we are going to do later is we
are going to say
can i search over can i find a very good
set of partitioning such that my
modularity score
will be as high as possible so that's
what we are going to do later
but now let's assume that
groups are given to us um and we want to
estimate how good of a clustering
are we having and the way the modularity
operates is the following we say
modularity q will be proportional to the
summation over all the groups
where for every group i want to ask how
many edges
are there between the members of the
group how many edges are
within the members of the group s minus
how many edges would i expect between
this
group s in some null random null model
right and if the group s has much more
edges between its members than what is
expected at random
then we have found a strong significant
cluster
and now you know what's the total
modularity of the network is the sum
over this modularity scores of
individual clusters
right so because we have this expected
number of edges within a group s
we need a null we need a null model
right we need a
random graph null model so now if we go
back to our subgraph mining
we talked about erdos rainey as an
example of around
of a model um and we also talked about
configuration model
as an example of a null model so let me
now tell you
uh and remind you about the
configuration model right which we
already talked about i think two
lectures ago when we talked about
subgraph mining the idea is the
following
given a real graph g on n nodes and m
edges
we want to create a random network g
prime
and we will refer to this random network
as a rewired network because essentially
it will mean
that every node keeps its degree number
of connections constant
but connects to random nodes rather to
than to the ones that
they are really in uh connected to in
the network so
this means that our network will have
the same degree distribution the same
degree sequence
but it will have random connections um
and we are going to consider graph g as
a multi-graph right we'll allow multiple
edges to exist
between the nodes so now you can say i
have these nodes
they have these spokes these are kind of
these half edges and now i want to
randomly connect uh these uh
end points and of course maybe between a
pair of nodes i will allow multiple
edges because perhaps both of these two
end points
randomly you know by chance decide to
connect to these two
end points so that'll be kind of a
double edge but for the purpose of this
uh discussion right now that's
completely fine and okay
so then you can ask yourself what is the
expected number of edges
between a pair of nodes i and j where
node i has degree
k sub i and node j has the degree
k sub j and the way to derive this
expression is the following you say um
what is the total number of uh edge end
points
basically this spokes number of spokes
is two times
n right every edge has two end points
every edge gets cut in half
if i have m edges then i have two times
m
endpoints this is why we have this guy
this thing here
then what is k sub j right k sub j
is the degree of uh node j it's the
number of
spokes it has so now i say um
for every no for every spoke of node i i
randomly pick another spoke so node
uh k sub j accounts for
k sub j divided by 2m fraction of all
available spokes right because this guy
could also decide to link to itself or
whatever else right
so now basically i say out of this case
by different
tries different random endpoint
selections
uh for each one of them has the
probability k
sub j divided by 2m to connect to node j
so now if i multiply this together i
basically say that the expected number
of edges
between i and j is simply the degree of
i times degree j
divided by 2m right so basically what
this means is that
the probability or the expected number
of edges is simply
equal to the product of the degrees of
the nodes
uh uh that we are interested in
right so um we have this very elegant
relationship
about the expected number of edges
between a pair of nodes
under this random configuration model
where nodes keep their degree
but the edges are assigned uh randomly
which basically means these endpoints
get randomly connected
with each other and we live in this kind
of multi-graph
world right so now that we have this
uh expected number of edges between uh i
and j
then i can say you know just like as a
as a as a
as a side calculation i can say okay so
what is the total
expected number of edges in this graph
g prime so basically i'm saying let's
sum over
all the nodes i all the nodes j
so all pairs of nodes and ask what is
the expected number of edges between
them
and of course i have to multiply this by
one half because when i go over all
pairs
it means i will count every edge twice
because i
j and j i will be counted twice
so if i work out this summations
explained here
basically i i get it's a summation of
the
um the degrees uh times another
summation over the degrees
uh the sum of the degrees is 2 times n
the sum over the degrees is 2 times
n and here i have divide by 1
1 over 2 times n that comes from here
times one half so i get
2 times m times 2 times m divided by 4
times n
you know 4's cancel out 1 m cancel out
and i'm
left with m so this means that this
small
this on this model both the degree
distribution and the total number of
edges
uh will be preserved and the expected
number of edges between a pair of nodes
is determined
by this formula k sub i times k sub j
divided by 2m so now
let's go back to the modularity so in
modularity we said
we have a number of edges between the
group s minus the expected number of
edges
within the group s so notice
that we are only interested in the edges
inside the group
and we are not explicitly minimizing for
the number of edges that cross
between groups this is kind of
implicitly accounted for
in modularity so how do we write this
out now
given what we learned about
configuration model as our null model
so we are going to write this the
following we are going to say modularity
of a group s in a graph
g is simply a sum
over the all the pairs of nodes
in the group this is whether that pair
of node disconnected
this simply counts number of edges
between the groups
and this second term says for every pair
i j i'm going to multiply the uh their
degrees divide by 2m so this is the
expected number of edges between a pair
of nodes
right so this is basically now saying
what is the real number of nodes
minus the expected number of nodes over
all the pairs of nodes in a given group
and now i sum this up over all the
groups
a little less from the partitioning of
nodes into group
into communities into groups capital s
and this uh factor 1 over 2m
is is a normalizing constant
so that our modularity metric q will
have ranged
from minus one to one right if uh all
the edges are
inside the group um uh uh
group s and uh somehow we would expect
very
little edges uh inside that group then
modularity will be
will be uh very close to one and if we
have kind of an anti-community
where we ex where we have no edges
between the
between the group but based on the
degrees of those nodes we would expect
a lot of edges then the value will be
negative will be minus one
so as i said the modularity can take a
value from minus one to one it is
positive if the number of edges within
the group
exceeds the the expected number of edges
and in reality in practice
if the modularity queue is greater than
let's say 0.3.7
this means that the graph has a
significant community structure that we
have identified
really strong clusters if our modularity
is in this range
so let me recap modularity
q is defined over an undirected graph
and a partitioning of nodes s
and it is intuitively defined as a
summation over all the groups
number of nodes between the members of
the group
minus number of um expected number of
edges between the members of the group
uh
given using the configuration model as a
null model
we then instantiate modularity using the
following formula
where we basically say for every group s
take
pairs of all pairs of nodes from the
group ask
whether a given pair is connected so
this summation will now
count uh the number of edges between the
members of the group
minus degree of one node degree of the
other node divided by twice the number
of edges in the network so this is the
expected number of edges between i and j
under the configuration model so this
difference tells us
um how how many m
what is the difference between the true
number of edges and expected number of
edges
inside a given group and now we sum this
up over all different groups
and we normalize it so this is how we
can
write it now that we have the modularity
score we basically have an objective
function
so now the question is can i identify
clusters communities by maximizing this
modularity score by basically
maximizing uh this metric so the
question will be
that we are going to address next is if
i uh
search over these groupings can i how do
i find
sets that have high modularity score